I'm Mike Massimino I'm a senior advisor
for space programs here at the intrepid
museum I'm also a engineering professor
at Columbia University and a former
astronaut the two missions that I were
on both were shuttle missions to service
Hubble Space Telescope first one was
sts-109 in 2002 and my second mission
was the final Hubble servicing mission
in 2009 sts-125 one of the defining
characteristics of the telescope is that
it was built and designed to be serviced
by astronauts and by the Space Shuttle
you know the size of the telescope was
dictated by the size of the payload Bay
you know in the the altitude of it was
dictated by the altitude that the help
that the shuttle kid could reach as an
astronaut it's a it's a it's a great
mission because you I had a sense that I
was contributing to something that was
really worthwhile my favorite images
were always the early release images the
ones that came down first when we worked
did our work on the telescope you know
we did as best we could but they really
can't take any observations for a while
and so for about a month there you don't
know for sure if what you did work he
thinks so but I go let's see what the
thing looks like so for my first flight
the Cole nebula is my favorite because I
was outside to install the ACS and
hooked it up and this beautiful image
the cone nebula which is kind of like a
star nursery and made like the front
page of the papers and stuff and that's
pretty cool you know again it's very
beautiful may not be the most beautiful
one may not be the most important
scientifically but it's my favorite
because it showed that the instrument
work my favorite one from my second
mission is just a dot of light
is the Space Telescope imaging
spectrograph first light it worked it
picked up a star and the thing powered
back up and the repair was correct and
worked and that that little image of
this is like faint star there's not one
of my favorite images it looks like a
light bulb
I guess we all kind of have this a you
know affection for the for the telescope
and what it does and it respect further
for the science that comes out of it but
also the engineering wonder that it is
it's a it's an amazing machine I think
it's a greatest scientific instrument
ever built